the test is ready rachel wrote ross a
letter
and demanded he read it before they got
back together
how many pages was that letter 18 pages
18 pages
front and back front and back is correct
oh my god here we go
where's the tissue box
[Music]
the cost of friends
wow does courtney still have her lines
written on the table
[Music]
we've literally just slipped right back
[Applause]
we regret we have such a bond from this
show
were ross and rachel on a break yes yes
yes yes [ __ ]
[Applause]
the first table read that's the first
time i laid eyes on any of you
everyone was so perfectly cast yeah
this is from the one where everyone
finds out
[Laughter]
i remember i went to the producer of the
show i was on
and he said that show's not gonna make
you a star
i remember one time i'd have to have the
news on and on the tv
was an aerial shot of each of our houses
oh geez i remember looking at it going
what my roof is a mess
it was an incredible time we became
best friends yeah i'm gonna cry now
when i watch the episodes i'm laughing
out loud because you all make me laugh
so hard i know you know how big the show
is what you have given so many people is
an experience of huge comfort oh my god
we felt like we had these friends i love
you guys so much
you